こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん　みなああさん　みなさあああああん
ｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ
ｱｱｱｱｯ  今日は
何気ない、何気ない普通の8月だと思いたいところなんですけども
今日はなんと！
あの！ガチャガチャごーちゃんが(？)
ガチャガチャ業界に今日は革新
大革命が起きる日になりました
なんと！
多分ネット見てる人は皆さん知っていると思うんですけども
というものがありまして
あのそもそも根本的なガチャガチャの話をさせていただきますと
あのガチャガチャってこうやって回した…
あの…
申し遅れましたわたくし、ガチャガチャ大好きでございます
よろしくお願いいたします
ガチャガチャってカプセルを開けると中に
フィギュアとかモノとかがこういろんなものが入ってるんですよ
それがまぁガチャガチャと言われるものでございます
本日から特定の店舗で発売されるようになりました
が！
ホームページとかめっちゃ調べてたんですよ僕
クッソ調べてたんですけど、あの結論から言いますと
あの田舎には売られていません
クッ
なのでもうもちろん、今僕が住んでる
買いに行くとしたら東京か愛知に行かなきゃいけないっていう状態だったんですけど
なんとですね
運のいいことに、今日は実は
UUUMのマネージャーさんが静岡に来てくださる予定があったんで
急遽UUUMのマネージャーさんに
ダンゴムシを買って来てくださいと
お願いさせていただきました
はじめ：ちょっと静岡に残念ながら売ってないみたいなんですよ
マネージャーさん：あ、まじすか　はいはい
はじめ：はい
はじめ：で、東京でしたら売ってるんですけど
マネージャー：ほうほう
はじめ：すいません、どうかよろしくお願い致します
マネージャー：そしたらじゃあ、ちょっとガチャガチャの詳細だけ
はじめ：はい
マネージャー：おねがいします
はじめ：すいません
マネージャー：はい
はじめ：すいません、よろしくお願いします
はじめ：すいません失礼致しました
はじめ：よろしくお願い致しました(？)
すいませんでしたｱｱｱｱ
ｱｱｱｱｱｱｱすいませんでした
ｱｱｱｱｱｱｱすいませんでしたｱｱｱｱｱ
UUUMの社員さんをパシッてしまいました
ｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ
はっはっはっはっはっ
これで、これで俺はダンゴムシのガチャを
手に入れるぞあはっはっはああああ
驚きの結果に
まぁちょっと嫌な予感はしてたんです、案の定
めっっっ!ちゃくちゃ売り切れてます
まず初手で秋葉原のお店に行ってもらったんですけども、こちら
ﾄﾞｫｲ
念のためにもう１ヶ所行きましたがそちらも
ﾀﾞｧｲ
さらに上野のもう１店舗
たくさんあるって言われたとこに行ってもらったんですけども、そちらも
やべ、やべ完全に出遅れた
そうなんですダンゴムシガチャ、今
それでも欲しい、それでも欲しいと思ってしまった僕は
メルカリをこう調べてみると
とんでもない価格で取引されていて
すごい嫌な気持ちになりました
ﾊﾝｯ！
僕のマネージャーさんは
取扱店舗に載っていないヨドバシカメラに
たまたま行ったところ
そのヨドバシカメラに
ダンゴムシガチャが売ってましたｱｱｱｱｱ
ありがとうございますううう
UUUM大好き（笑）、UUUM大好き（笑）
静岡ではまず手に入らない
東京でもまぁ、まずもう手に入らない
超レアな伝説のダンゴムシガチャ
こちちらにあります、こちらです
ﾊｯｯ
ｗｗｗｗこ、
これらしいですよ
すごくね？
あのガチャガチャってカプセルの中に入っているんですけども
もうこれ自体がカプセルになっているみたいです
そしてお値段なんと衝撃
1回…
５００円です
ってかめっちゃリアルみたいな
前評判がすごい良くて
めっちゃ欲しいと思ってたんですよ情報出た時
でもやっぱ案の定バカ売れしてて
ほんとに手に入んないらしいです
うぉ、うわっうわ、うわっ
すごいすごい、待って…
光沢がすごい
うっうっうっ
この垣間見えるこの中の感じがすごいリアル
ちょっと待ってｗｗすごいな本当にｗ
じゃあ早速開けてみましょう　オープン！
うっ、うわあああああああああ
うわ、待ってうううう
あれ待って、壊れちゃった待ってくれ待って
待って！待って！
ううううう、ううううううううう
待って、すぐ死んじゃうなアナタ
あっはｗデケェｗｗｗ
めちゃんこデカイですけど
すげぇリアルです
はい中は、ｸﾞｴｴｴｴｴｴｴｴｴｴｴ
待って、危な
スッゲーリアルですねぇ
ダンゴムシの構造を徹底研究し
丸まる体を再現した衝撃のスケールモデル
えーっとまずは、
足を全部外側に開いてって書いてあります
開いてみましょう
うええええええええ
はい、全部開くことができました
はいｗというわけで完成しました
普通のダンゴムシよりはるかに大きいんですけど
キモっ
うわこれやばいなぁ、急にあったらほんとに怖いなぁ
１体だけだと物足りない
なんかもう人気すぎて個数制限とかあるみたいなんで
そのお店で買える可能な限りの数カッテキテクダサイッテイッタトコロ(突然のかたこと)
残り5個は普通のあのダンゴムシの色なんですけども
こっちがなんかアルビノですね
白くなっちゃったダンゴムシ
たまに居たんだよな白いやつ
ウイルスに侵食されて青くなっちゃったダンゴムシもいます
合計3色になってますね
いや、8匹手にいれれたのデカイっすよこれ
ちょっと全部開封していきましょう
ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝ･ﾍﾟﾝ♪　ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝ♪　ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝ･ﾍﾟﾝ♪　ﾍﾟ~~~ﾝ☆
ﾃﾝﾃﾝ･ﾃﾃﾝ･ﾃﾝﾃﾝ･ﾃﾃﾝ･ﾃﾝﾃﾝｯﾃﾃﾃテンテンテンテンﾃﾝｯ☆
なんか…
売れる理由がわかる気がします
結構思ったよりリアルなんで
なんかどっか置いとけば誰かビビるんじゃないかなってことで
適当にどこかに置いといてみようと思います
ではいこう
はじめ仕掛け中
(やふへゐ先生：すまんな、モザイクがめんどくさかった)
だいちぃ：やばいまじでほんと、うわあああなに！？！？
だいちぃ：うわっ、あっなにこれ！！！
ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟ　ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟ
ﾍﾟｰｰﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟﾝｰﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟｰﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟｰﾍﾟｰﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟｰﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟﾝﾍﾟｰ
ﾍﾟｯﾍﾟｯﾍﾟｯﾍﾟｯ
ﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾍﾟﾝｯ☆